The mind-blowing finale of I Am Not Okay With
This left us with so many questions about
Syd's powers and the identity of the mysterious
figure.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video, I'll be breaking all of that down,
and explaining the secret conspiracy that
led to Syd's superpowers, plus Season 2 theories.
Obviously, spoilers ahead, so take care if
you haven't seen the show yet.
The first season ends with a literal bang
when Syd's powers explode Brad's head at the
school Homecoming.
As gruesome as it is, it's also designed to
be kind of funny because Brad unsuspectingly
predicted his own demise earlier that same
day:
"Let's just say that tonight's gonna be f***ing
mind-blowing."
When Syd flees the scene, she returns to the
tower that she went to the previous time her
powers became massively out of control.
As she contemplates her future, we hear whispering
voices and a dark cloud of particles arrives
on the platform behind her, taking on a human
form.
"Who are you?
Should I be afraid?
They should be afraid."
So, who is this strange, shadowy figure that's
been stalking Syd?
This entity can dissolve into a dark cloud
as we saw when it was watching Syd after her
training session with Stan.
On the one hand, the show seems to hint it
could be her father or a vision of him.
For example, when Syd mentions to her school
counsellor that she thought a man had been
following her, Ms. Cappriotti asks Syd if
it looked like her father.
And basically suggests that the figure was
just a grief hallucination of her dead dad
caused by her feelings of loss over him.
However, when this mystery figure finally
appears in front of Syd on the platform, she
doesn't recognise him.
We also know that Syd's mother said that when
her father was still alive, he believed somebody
was following him too.
Curiously, in the graphic novel that the show
is based on, a shadowy, black form appears
in a scene where Syd is having sex.
And in the comic, it's Syd's powers which
unconsciously create this menacing entity.
So, in the TV show, could this ghostly figure
be something that Syd has created from her
inner abilities without realising?
When Syd and Stan are reviewing the stolen
library security cam footage, Stan even comments,
"That just looks like your shadow."
Whoever or whatever it might be, the ending
is setting this mystery man up as a mentor
figure for Syd in the second season.
Stan, who already thinks of Syd as a superhero,
pointed out to her that this is classic comic
book storytelling.
"So each of these comics features an unknown
visitor.
A professor, a wise old sage, some form of
mentor figure,
you know, who visits the hero,
explains their abilities, the mythology behind
them,
and how they can harness those powers for
good."
This being is likely there to help Syd properly
understand how to control her powers, and
maybe even harness them in a positive way.
"I mean, if I really can make a nose bleed
with my brain, then maybe it can be used for
good."
So far, Syd's struggled to manage her powers.
She's tried blocking out negative thoughts
and smoking weed which seem to help somewhat.
But these aren't real, permanent solutions
as any type of strong emotion or panic trigger
her powers in unpredictable and dangerous
ways.
Season 1 then is Syd's superhero origin story,
and the show heavily hints that she received
them from her father.
When Stan tries to figure out how Syd got
her powers, he suggests that
"Sometimes a person inherits their abilities."
And Syd's mother also tells her
"When it comes to your dad, you have this
gift."
There are also obvious parallels in terms
of their shared telekinetic powers between
Syd and Eleven from Stranger Things whose
own powers originate from the clandestine
MK Ultra experiments carried out on her mother.
However, the origin of Syd's father's powers
is, as yet, unknown.
In fact, the show's co-creator and director,
Jonathan Entwistle has said that "there is
[…] a much bigger, under-the-surface conspiracy
[to do with the powers] that goes back much
further."
Which makes me wonder whether Syd's father
was experimented on by the military after
he joined the marines?
And when Stan is trying to figure out the
origin for Syd's powers, one of the possibilities
he mentions is
"Secret military experiment?"
Syd's father could have been involved in covert
military research and trials designed to turn
him into a kind of super-soldier.
One of the best-known comic book characters
who underwent this type of experiment is Steve
Rogers, aka Captain America.
Another hint towards experimentation or perhaps
a chemical accident being the cause of her
father's powers is that we get a number of
scenes in Syd's chemistry class.
"As the temperature increases, if an atom
loses one or more electrons, it becomes oxidized!"
And the blackboard behind him is also filled
with numerous details about acid and alkaline
reactions.
We also learn that during her father's final
tour, he was the only human being who survived
an enormous explosion.
What if that explosion was set off by some
kind of bio-weapon that triggered a mutation
in him?
Alternatively, the explosion might have gone
off next to a chemical facility and killed
everyone else but gave him powers?
Or perhaps he'd already been experimented
on, along with others, and the explosion was
deliberately engineered to test whether any
of them would survive the blast, and only
he did.
X-Men characters like Wolverine and Deadpool
received superhuman healing abilities after
being experimented on.
In fact, I Am Not Okay With This has numerous
allusions to the X-Men from Stan's "Not Men"
comic book,
the Wolverine-like spiked gloves that Syd's
brother designs for his superhero suit,
and the school is also "Home of the Wolverines".
Comic book characters have often received
their powers through accidents or mutations.
Daredevil got his powers when he was blinded
during a chemical accident and Carol Danvers,
aka Captain Marvel, was an ordinary human
who received her powers when she absorbed
the energy from an experimental light-speed
engine that blew up.
And there's also Stan's "Spider Tales" comic,
referencing the radioactive arachnid bite
that gave Spider-Man his abilities.
At the end of the season, when the mystery
figure tells Syd
"They should be afraid"
he could be referring to the people involved
in the conspiracy rather than the townspeople.
For example, if it is the ghost of her father,
he could be looking for revenge.
He could have even been murdered and his death
made to look like a suicide, remember he never
left a note.
Another possibility is that there are supernatural
or even alien forces at play here, given the
mystery man's ability to disappear into thin
air.
There's a hint to this in the poster for the
movie They Came From Beyond Space which is
displayed quite prominently in Stan's room.
In that movie, space aliens attempt to enslave
humans by possessing them.
Whether Syd will be able to keep her powers
under the radar in the second season is unclear
because her diary which Brad was reading out
went missing on the dance floor during the
panic after his head exploded.
It'll be interesting to see how Brad's death
is explained by investigators, but some suspicion
may fall on Syd given how he was ranting at
her just before he died.
Especially if her diary ends up in the hands
of someone who decides to reveal her secret
to fellow students, teachers, or the police,
or perhaps even ends up blackmailing her about
it.
Now, if you've read the original graphic novel,
you might be thinking that ultimately Syd's
journey will end in tragedy, because...
spoilers for the comic book...,
Syd commits suicide when she discovers she
can't handle her powers.
However, Entwistle has specifically said that
the Netflix version of the story will not
be as "macabre" and will instead expand the
world of the graphic novel.
To be honest, a suicide storyline as the final
destination for Syd would be a rather bleak
way to treat a character who's not only grappling
with grief, but also confronting her burgeoning
sexuality and feelings of social isolation,
who could hopefully still find a path to dealing
with all that.
Entwistle has also said that while the comic
is "a story about mental illness, and essentially
suicide", what he wanted to do with the show
was build out "the backstory of how [Syd]
got [to that point]"
and "take all the elements of a journey of
somebody being confused by lots of different
things in their life [..]
and make a different type of genre show."
So, did the ending of I Am Not Okay With This
blow your mind?
And who do you think the mystery figure is?
Leave your thoughts and theories in the comments
below.
If you enjoyed this, then a thumbs-up and
a share are hugely appreciated.
Tap left for my latest Netflix videos on Locke
and Key, Stranger Things and Chilling Adventures
of Sabrina.
Or tap right for another video you're sure
to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!